Behind me are eight entrepreneurs,
all competing for $100,000 and this
golden ticket, which gives them a year
of guidance from myself and my team
behind our $250 million per [music] year
portfolio.
>> How much the golden ticket actually
worth to me?
>> It's priceless.
>> Absolutely priceless.
>> Just so you know what's at stake here,
this golden ticket has the potential to
save or [music] scale some of these
businesses they've spent years building.
It's
>> the culmination of my life's work.
>> I left a six figure career after my mom
passed away. Some will scale.
>> I've made over $20 million from nothing.
[music]
>> Some will fail. I can't think of a time
I would have done that.
>> Dude, I need a mobile.
>> And the winner is
>> So, welcome everyone to round one. This
is the qualification round. So, I met
with all you guys 90 days ago and I gave
you a step-by-step road map on how to
scale your businesses. And since the
goal of this competition is to find the
business that we together want to work
with, I want to see how well you've
implemented the advice and how much
you've all grown since the last time we
spoke. Now, the [music] stakes. There
will be four eliminations this round and
it will all be based on growth. We're
going to be asking you guys the same
questions so that my partners have the
exact same context and intel that I
have. And so for those who don't know,
this is Shanza, our uh CEO and press,
head honcho of all things. This is my
lovely wife, Leila, most importantly,
but also uh my forever business partner
and uh what is your official? Oh,
chairwoman ch.
>> You haven't known my title in a decade
since we've been working together. Leila
oversees all of our investments and so I
invited both of them here so we could
make the absolute best judgment on who
to uh select. So business owner number
one uh please go ahead. [music]
>> My name is Tina Sue and I coach parents
of children with autism and ADHD and
speech delay trailing 12 months. I did
$1.1 million.
>> Okay. Can you step up to the center?
>> Hi.
>> Hi. All right. So Tina, 90 days ago you
said that your constraint was you as the
bottleneck. And so to fix that, the
biggest levers that we identified were
number one that you'd build a system so
your team could answer repeat questions
without you. Number two, fix the pricing
for your one-on-one time. And then
number three is we had to cut your 3 to
4 hour pitch down to a tight 45minute
webinar. And then be clear about when
you're teaching versus when you're
selling and not being afraid to really
sell.
>> So did you do it?
>> I did everything. I executed everything
and I ended up doing 13 weekly webinars.
I sold 232
enrollment spots.
>> Amazing.
>> Compared to 75 before.
>> So more than more than three eggs.
>> So how much did you grow from doing
those webinars and implementing
everything?
>> Yeah. My 12-month run rate was $918,000
before. Now is at 1.84 million.
>> Hell yeah. In 90 days.
>> In 90 days.
>> That's so good.
>> Thank you.
>> Next contestant, can you introduce
yourself?
>> My name is Zad Oasi, MD. I own Precision
Health Concier Medicine. We're a
preventative medicine practice in the
concierge space. Uh trailing 12 month
revenue is 3.2 million.
>> All right. Please step up. Yes. So 90
days ago, Zed, uh you said the
constraint was marketing. So to fix
that, the biggest levers that we
identified were number one, turning turn
every visit into a built-in referrals.
Uh number two was give away something
big instead of discounting. And then
number three, uh sell where the rich
customers already gather. So show up at
the local events with a flashy kind of
like healthcare machine uh to hook in
and then sell the higher income
prospects.
>> Did you implement?
>> Uh it was a little bit complicated for
me. Um, right after we talked, I had
realized basically where I am is very
seasonal. So, there were pretty much no
events. So, I realized I can use my
relationships that already exist. Like a
lot of my patients live in country
clubs. So, one of the first patients, we
did a country club event and other
patients saw it advertised and so they
got excited and they came to us like,
"Hey, can you do this at my country
club?"
>> So, we're actually seeing the delivery
channel of the events that was
recommended work especially with almost
no CAC.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is amazing. So, tell us about your
growth.
So 90 days ago um we were estimating
that we would clear 4 million um run
rate and now it's closer to 4.5.
>> Got it. Rock and roll.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Give him a little hand. Give
him a little hand.
>> Next contestant. Can you introduce
yourself?
>> I'm Mim Jeninson and I teach crafters
how to make stickers. My revenue for the
last 12 months was between 850 and
900,000 US.
>> Go Mim. Selling stickers.
>> So good.
>> Yeah. You're all in the wrong business.
That's all.
>> I know. What What are we doing? She's
like, "I'm sorry. We work so hard.
[laughter] You're selling stickers."
>> Yeah.
>> So, Mim, step on up.
>> Yeah. Mim.
>> All right. So, uh, 90 days ago, you said
your constraint was not enough
customers. And so, to fix that, we
identified two big levers. So, number
one was spend way more on ads. And then
number two was replace many cheap
courses and products with one much
higher priced annual offer.
>> Were you able to implement the ideas?
>> Absolutely. Everything on the list.
everything and a little bit more.
>> That's awesome. And did you grow?
>> I did. Yeah. So before my revenue was
around the 800, 850, 900 depending on
the Australian conversion.
>> Um and then projected now for the next
12 months is more like 1.76 millions.
And you may remember that I spoke to you
about my goal being to be able to pay
off my home loan and then to be able to
buy my mom's house um for her as well to
pay her back the money. And that is just
so much closer than I thought it ever
would be.
>> Fantastic.
>> Oh, it's amazing. Congratulations.
>> Give it up for him. Thank you. Good job.
[applause]
>> Next contestant. Can you introduce
yourself?
>> My name is Nas. I run flex moving. From
the name we do move people from point A
to point B. In the last 12 months, we
did $400,000.
>> All right. Nas, come on up.
>> Good. Good.
>> Got it. Nas.
>> All right. The Phoenix. Um, [laughter]
>> good to see you.
>> Yeah, good to see you, too, man. So, 90
days ago, you said your constraint was
not enough leads and customers. And so
to fix that, the biggest levers were
number one, stop competing on hourly
price. Number two is with that is sell
to the rich, right? With a VIP tier
versus a standard tiers.
>> Were you able to implement the ideas?
>> Yes, I did do some flat rates and I had
closed my biggest move ever of $15,000.
It's not quite like your move at 25, but
we get in there, right?
>> By the way, I watched that episode and
heard what she said about me.
>> What did I say? You were like, "She
definitely spent like $25,000 for
[laughter] the
>> because like I'll tell you when I moved
I honestly have no idea what I paid, but
I'm guessing it's probably in the
neighborhood of like $25,000. I have no
clue."
>> Did we spend 25?
>> No.
>> Really?
>> Less.
>> How much was it?
>> I'm a bargain shopper. Anyways, um
[laughter]
>> no VIP for Leila.
>> I'll get I'll get you VIP next time. We
won't be
>> I told this story to inspire. I
[laughter] just wanted to give a great
example.
>> You didn't even look at the bank
account.
That being said, how much did you grow?
>> So, we were at 360 back then. We're
currently on um on track to do 1.03
million.
>> Dude, congratulations. Give it up for
>> Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> How are you, man?
>> Thank you,
>> sir. Paul,
>> uh my name is Paul Fontinelli. I run
Boulder Adventure Park. Our trailing 12
months is 4.8 million. So 90 days ago,
you said the constraint was cash flow
and so the business was running at half
capacity and you were bleeding money
with no fast way to bring in revenue and
you already put your 401k into the
business to keep it alive.
>> Honestly, the hardest day was when my
CFO sends me a cash flow. We're not
going to make it to today. [music] Like
we were that short and that's when I
said it's all in. I looked at my 401k
and I was like
put it put it all in. [snorts]
Now, when you have a small team, you
can't split focus across multiple
offers. So, you had to pick one and go
all in. And so, we need to decide on
running one grand slam offer, which was
we decided for summer camp uh and to do
a giveaway to generate lots of leads and
bring in cash quickly.
>> Did you implement?
>> Oh, we definitely implemented. Uh to say
that we got a lot of leads is an
understatement. So many so that it was
just a flood. We got over 3,700 leads.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Uh in the giveaway, which was
phenomenal. Um, we struggled to be very
candid with you down the conversion
pipeline of that. I don't think our team
had ever seen that volume of leads. So,
it was a good problem.
>> When you saw the struggle in conversion,
um, how did it impact growth? Love to
hear about the growth numbers.
>> I love that. I think I'd like to talk
about growth beyond just the numbers. I
mean, the numbers are definitely
something I can go into. I think one of
the things I'm most proud of is I stood
in front of Alex and the phrase that hit
me the hardest is he said, "Your
business is a mess." And at that [music]
time, it absolutely was. There's a lot
of reasons for it. I don't like to make
excuses. At that time, I was at a very
challenging point. Since that time,
we've been able to get all of our
metrics together in a way that I have
every number you'd ever dream of that I
can talk through through every piece of
the business.
>> That's [music] awesome. Can you also
share the numbers?
>> Yeah, run rate I think was 4.4 million.
Run rate now is 4 million cuz we had a
little bit of a lull kind of getting
through this and where we want to go in
the future.
>> No, I appreciate it. Give it up for
Paul. Great job, Paul.
>> Thank you.
And now it's time for our first
elimination.
So Paul, um, as of right now, you grew
the least and so unfortunately you'll
[music] be eliminated at this round.
So right now, these are the four to
beat.
>> Well done.
>> And, uh, we will continue.
I feel like I grew so much in the ways
that are not quantitative. The biggest
improvement in the 90 days was really
getting our metrics clean. Working with
acquisition is a no-brainer. Like the
processes that you put in place. I mean,
in my case, you you really can't assess
where that bottleneck is. If you don't
know everything about the business, the
struggle is real, but I wouldn't change
it. Caleb,
let's uh let's do it.
>> My name is Caleb with the K. I own Keys
Roofing Company. We've done 250,000
within the last 12 months for trailing
12 month revenue.
>> So 90 days ago you were 6 weeks into
business, which is insane. Um [laughter]
>> Wait, seriously?
>> Yeah, you started it 6 weeks before
this. So um at the time you were doing
both roof repairs, which were small
jobs, and then roof replacements,
[music] which made paid more.
>> Um the opportunity was that your
competitors generally didn't want to do
the repairs cuz they paid less. And so
to capitalize on this, the biggest
levers that we identified were number
one to chase their repairs, not just the
big roof replacements, while raising
prices and increasing [music] volume,
and then adding the mini close script to
increase close rates and build trust.
[music] And the mini close script is
like my absolute all-time favorite sales
script. I've spent so long honing those
four steps to make it just crush.
>> Did you get a chance to implement the
strategies?
>> 100%. So, I was re-watching my episode
and Alex talked about systemizing the
living out [laughter] of the door
knocking piece.
>> Word for word. Yeah, it sounds sounds
about right. Had the menu close work.
>> And the menu closed was crazy. It was
absolutely insane. So like it enhances
trust and authenticity and once I give
those recommendations like these people
are so happy to give me their money
because I've made it easy for them.
>> Would you say it slaps?
>> It slaps so hard. [laughter]
>> How did that translate to grow?
>> It was 370,000 before and now it's 2
million.
>> And now it's 2 million.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. That's a large difference.
Everyone give it up for Caleb.
[applause]
And now we'll be doing another
elimination.
See here, Dr. Z, you are the uh right
now the current lowest growth of the
four on the on the panel.
>> The experience pushed me to focus in a
way that I wouldn't have otherwise. My
goal was to find like-minded physicians.
Some of that has already happened. And
so the fact that any of them actually
reached out to me, it makes it worth it.
Hi, step on up.
>> My name is Hussi Nazir. I own Smile
Magic Holistic Dentistry. Our trailing
12-month revenue was 2.2 million. So 90
days ago, your constraint was that your
dad was the only dentist who could do
the clinical work across your three
locations. And so the whole business
[music] was capped by uh his calendar,
right? And so to fix that, the two big
lovers um that we identate, we
identified more, but two big [music]
ones were hire more dentists to take off
uh you know, work from your dad's plate
so that he could become shift shift his
kind of identity from being the best
dentist to being the best teacher of
dentists. The second was aggressively
raise prices since you had a 90% close
rate, meaning the prices were too low.
And then we added a little bit [music]
of a juice to the sales motion.
>> Yeah.
>> Did you do it?
>> Yes. Yes. So, day one, got back home,
told my dad, "You know what? Surprise,
surprise, we're going to increase prices
again." And he was he was like, "Again?"
Like, we just raised prices. And next
day, he got like the positive
reinforcement. We closed a $70,000 case,
paid up front in Newport Beach.
>> That tends to do it.
>> Yeah.
>> And it was chef's kiss.
>> Yeah. He was like, he called me. He was
like, "You won't guess what just
happened."
>> And I'm like,
>> "Yeah." and he was like it was amazing.
>> Nothing sells like proof. Good job.
>> It's really impressive especially like
there are so many people in similar
industries that I think um finding other
doctors delegating the all the things
that doctors do. So like kudos to you
for like zero
>> just hustle
Thank you. In the past 90 days
we have grown more than he has in the
past 30 years of
>> So how much have you grown exactly? So
in the past 90 days it was 1.73
million
>> at the beginning and then as of right
now our revenue run rate is just over 4
million.
>> In 90 days
>> in 90 days.
>> So good.
>> Well, first let's give it up for Hi.
[applause]
>> All right. It's time for our third
elimination.
>> Nas. Uh right now your revenue grew the
least of the four people that we have
right now. So um you've been eliminated
this round, but you're still in
everyone's hearts.
>> I appreciate you deeply. Thank you,
>> dude. Congrats, man.
>> Thank you.
>> You can step on back.
>> I feel great. Like generally from the
bottom of my heart, I feel awesome.
Everybody has won in my eyes. We all
won. Oh, it's a lot less emotional and I
definitely have a clear path of where
I'm headed. 1,000%. Like what? Now it's
it's super clear. Like before it was
super ambiguous, super blurry. Um but
after that conversation, I went back
home and I just thought about everything
that needs to be done. And when you do
at least like you do just like 10% of it
and you see what's possible, like I can
only imagine if you do like 100% of
this, what could actually be possible.
>> Okay, last but not least, Joey.
>> My name is Joey Goon. I run a company
called Utopia Experience. We are an
event planning company.
>> Awesome. What was uh Trailing 12?
>> 1.3 million.
>> All right. All right. So 90 days ago,
the real problem was that your prices
were actually made up on the spot and
your margins were too thin and your
sales team was converting [music] far
worse than you were. So we had kind of a
number of different issues.
>> And so to fix that, the biggest levers
we identified, we identified a lot, but
just big ones were number one, build a
real pricing formula so that every deal
is profitable by design rather than by
accident.
>> Uh number two was have your sales reps
uh just book meetings and not uh just
close deals since you're currently much
more effective at closing. So we kind of
shifted the whole sales pipeline up a
step. And then number three, going after
B2B events and sponsored booths puts you
in front of hundreds of your ideal
customers at once rather than chasing
the individual accounts uh one at a
time.
>> So, did you get a chance to implement
the strategies?
>> Yes. Yes, we did. Uh we did all the
things. We immediately booked a
sponsorship to an event that happened 2
weeks after I left here in filming. Uh
that sponsorship was a $15,000
investment. The result of that was
$670,000 of closed business. Damn.
>> That I'm excited to go back to. Matter
of fact, my team closed 300,000 this
morning.
>> Oh yeah. [laughter]
Like I'm in Vegas and they send me a
message and they're like, "Go take it
home, bro." Like we, you know, we've got
>> like you can put a hundred on black.
>> Yeah. Which is great.
>> So uh so you have you'd made just under
3 million from a $15,000 single
sponsored event using the stuff that we
outlined. That seems like it was a
pretty good return. 200x return.
>> That's chill.
>> What does the actual growth look like?
Like revenue profit?
>> Yeah. So we did 1.3 million in 2025. Uh,
we're on path now to do 4.1 million.
>> Amazing.
>> Over in in 90 days.
>> Wow.
>> All right.
>> And that doesn't include the 2 million
that still sits in the pipeline.
>> Hell yeah.
>> So good.
>> Amazing.
>> All right. So, uh, give it up for Joey
for actually taking action.
>> I also think that there is these baked
in beliefs that certain channels don't
work, like sponsorships don't work or
events don't work. Uh kudos to all of
you for taking a belief that you had and
breaking that which is what has kind of
created this transformational growth
through all of you. So great job.
>> And now it's time for our last
elimination around one.
And so unfortunately MIM even though you
had a monster, you know, almost $800,000
in annualized revenue growth, um it's
the least, which is insane to even say
of the four remaining contestants.
>> You can change the rules. I'm okay
staying. [laughter]
I've got more things to say. So,
>> no, you're good.
>> Thank you. Good luck every
>> amount of times I thought to myself, I
wish he'd just get his eyes on my
business. Like, if I could only have 5
minutes with Alex, this would change
everything and it gives you the drive.
It gives you the the road map. It shifts
everything and it's all you need. We
don't need permission. We don't need
someone to give us a shove forward. It
just someone who you respect to say you
can do this. I'm so thrilled with the
results that I've had in the past 90
days and I'm really grateful for this
opportunity.
>> I'll just make the the obvious
observation which is that like the
numbers that you guys all shared were
still monster you know number growth in
terms of revenue and profit and hearing
you know more growth in in 90 days than
28 years or you know doing 3 or 4x in
terms of how much your revenue is doing
again in just 90 days. I think the more
important thing I want for the audience
or anyone watching at home is like you
really can change your stars in a very
short period of time if you have the
right strategy and I think the big part
is the big conviction and I think you
guys took absolutely massive action for
a number of reasons and I think the
biggest one should be for you and your
customers. That's the real game. So
>> I think there's a correlation between
the amount of conviction there is in the
plan that was set with Alex and the
success that I'm seeing in the numbers.
Um sometimes there's things that get in
the way, but it's really clear the
enthusiasm translates into results. And
I think sometimes the more critical and
logical that we can be, the worse it is
for us sometimes. And so I just think
kudos to everyone who just massively
executed because we like to say at
acquisition.com test and learn. Um and
you don't learn anything by debating in
your head or debating in a room or
debating amongst people on your team.
You just learn by executing ruthlessly.
So really cool. [music]
>> This round is the implementation round.
So, this is where we're going to go
deeper into the road map and see exactly
how you implemented each of the pieces
of advice that I gave earlier. And so,
we're going to have two eliminations
this round based on how you answer the
questions. So, just tell the truth. That
is my big my big piece of advice.
>> What?
>> Don't be a shitty person. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Don't do that. And so, Joey,
you can come back up and we're going to
talk about the road map. So the last
round we kind of briefly touched on it,
but this one I have all the notes uh
from our talk. And so we had uh five big
things that we asked you to do. And so
the first one was to change the offer.
And so we wanted you to build a cost
basis quote generator and then add a
price lock guarantee and then add
prepaid and multi-event discounts.
>> Yes.
>> So how did you do on that one?
>> Uh we did it. We built the uh the price
module within the first 30 days. what
we've implemented multi-year contracts.
We took our average contract price from
44,000 to an average of $200,000
just by implementing that one little
thing. The next thing was the sales
motion, right? So, we wanted to
restructure uh the team so they would
set appointments so that you would just
do closing. Um we added the events per
your question. We deployed three VSSLs
was the goal. We wanted to do same day
quotes ideally and then run a daily
cadence with LinkedIn outreach. So, of
those things, which ones did you were
you able to do? Uh we did all of them.
>> Hell yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> So what's the close rate now?
>> Uh close rate is 48%. Which for me
>> was it before?
>> Uh it was 44.
>> Okay. And you just 5x the price.
>> Yeah.
>> Chill. Next one was B2B events as an
acquisition channel. Uh so buying booths
at as many speaking [music] events um as
you could and then build kind of the the
20 mistakes talk with the QR optin. So
>> how'd that go?
>> We're I'm really now aggressively
pursuing speaking as the you know the
second most profitable acquisition
channel. So that's kind of like in
progress.
>> Yeah, that's in progress. I'm speaking
at an event next month in Denver.
>> Yeah. Last but not least was content. So
content in organic. So making content
aimed at recruiting sales people and
repurping event footage as social proof
for outbound.
>> In the process right now of building an
application page with a VSSL and working
with recruiters.
>> So changed the offer,
>> changed the pricing, changed the sales
motion, [music] narrowed down the
acquisition channel to be B2B events and
sponsorships. Yeah.
>> What's in motion right now is the
organic to some degree [music] and the
the speaking part of on you.
>> Yeah.
>> Correct.
>> What was unexpected?
>> We've we've made a lot of sacrifices
over the 90 days to do what we needed to
do to get the business to where it is.
Um and now being able to see the light
at the end of the tunnel on the other
side of that and what we're building. um
getting to the point where, you know,
now we could like now we want to get to
the point where we could buy back our
time and be the parents that we I mean
not that we were we weren't shitty we've
never been shitty parents, right? Like I
just want to for the record,
>> but um but working those like 16 hour
[laughter]
16-hour days um like I just you know I
I'm grateful to see what we're building.
Um but the hardest thing was the the
compromises and the sacrifices that we
had to make to implement all of these
things. Um, but it's, you know, look at
where we are.
>> I would also say like 90 days is so
short
>> in the grand scheme of things
>> and compared to the amount of people
that I talked to that have sacrificed
years and years with their kids and lost
the childhoods and seeing them as babies
and seeing their first steps like
>> the fact that you guys are to implement
it that quickly and you can only look
back and say for 90 days we did that.
>> I see that as a huge win.
>> Absolutely. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Thank you for that.
>> Good job.
>> Thank you. Thank you guys. [applause]
Let's go, Caleb. We had six things that
we outlined as kind of um core focus.
So, number one was the offer. So, making
repairs the main engine um and raising
the average repair ticket price from
2500 to 5 grand and uh adding a speed
upsell and hiring the in-house repair
technician uh to keep the menu narrow.
How'd that [music] one go?
>> Everything's been fantastic. So, the
hiring the repair tech has really
unlocked my ability on the door to door
to be able to sell more and then get
[music] things done absolutely quickly.
The VSSL while done still needs a little
bit of time. [music]
>> So, menu sale, yes. Offer, yes. VSSL in
progress,
>> correct?
>> All right. Doortodoor army. [music] So,
recruiting two to three salespeople with
a million or more in prior production.
>> So, with that, yes, I have a gentleman
that I'm bringing onto the team as of
Wednesday of next week. I've been
bringing in people that have so much
more experience than I.
>> Like my average employee is 40.
>> Do they see what I'm doing?
>> Ancient.
>> Well,
>> well, [laughter]
well, hear me out. Here we are. Hear me
out. Hear me out. Here we go.
>> They call them the elderly.
>> Is [laughter]
>> the reason I'm able to attract that
level of candidate is they see my
dedication. And that's why I've been so
attracted to the content, everything
that you guys make because despite the
>> Because we're older.
>> Well, no. despite the despite the
position that you're in is like people
want to work for somebody that they
trust with their future and I have
employees that'll work at 7:30 8 9 still
texting me because they understand that
I'm still up and I'm still making this
happen with every fiber of my being. So
>> So that one's in progress.
>> The membership was progress update on
that one.
>> So with the membership now that I'm
doing more full replacements I'm
starting to pitch that. I'm still trying
to figure out like like I said the best
way to go about yeah to script it. And I
think transparently there's been so many
action steps that I had that I'm really
just trying to do all of it. And
>> there's maybe some things I've deemed
like more important than others. So I
still need to continue to implement
that. It's just there's so much stuff
quite honestly.
>> I appreciate the honesty.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> What was hard? What was hard then based
on the strategies that Alex laid out for
you? given up control,
you know that, oh, they can't do it the
same way that I do it. And at that same
point, to take a step back is to be the
leader and like actually stepping into
the coaching role. [music] I would say
that was the most difficult, but it it's
trusting your people. And they've shown
me that the the task that I put out
there, I can trust them to do it. I
don't put up the catch-all anymore. I
think it's really cool because you've
compressed a lot of entrepreneurial
lessons is what I hear from you into a
short amount of time. Like I hear you
talking about the the lessons that
you've learned, not just the things that
you've implemented. If you continue to
do that over the next year, two years,
like dude, you're going to blow. Super
dangerous. It's like I feel like 15
years older from [laughter] 90 days.
Well, it's the amount of rest. Tell me
about it.
>> Quite honestly. Yeah. But like, think
about it. It's like company,
>> which is super old by the [laughter]
way.
>> Uh,
>> okay. We'll give it up for Caleb. Yeah.
>> Good job. [applause]
>> Okay, Tina, now you're up.
>> Tina,
>> let's talk about this road map and
>> All right.
>> and go into it. Offer-wise, we said we
needed to restructure the pricing and
billing. So, you had like $150 to which
was discontinued, right?
>> Getting rid of that. Y
>> and then we had a much more expensive
option. So, walk me through it. How'd
that go?
>> So, it's a 2500. It used to be 12 month.
I've changed it to six month.
>> Okay. So, and I've also changed the
upsell for the next level in the middle
of the 3 month versus at the end of the
12 month.
>> Well done. The Alex roll over. Of
course.
>> Yeah.
>> That that that single offer has made me
>> so much.
>> Like probably $50 million. Like that has
made me a tremendous amount of money.
>> Yeah.
>> Probably more.
>> I put that in right away and I was like,
>> "Wo, it works.
>> It works.
>> It works." It's funny cuz uh Caleb we
were saying earlier like the [music]
it's it's the tiny little scripting
lines. It's two or three sentences. And
so like I think many people do not fully
appreciate the value of like the money
models book because like you just ran
the manuscript and it was like oh
this prints. It's not just how you sell,
it's when you sell. Okay. Uh delivery.
So build an AI dashboard so the team
works outside the messaging platform.
>> Absolutely. So I got that done. I'm out
of Telegram completely because inspired
by what you told me to do, I ended up
building nine other tools for my
business and it's
>> ribbon
>> changing changing everything.
>> The the last one we had was to get more
traffic. So we wanted to capture and
distribute the Q&A for like your content
library. So where you at with that one?
>> Um so we're currently publishing 60
pieces of new content.
>> Okay. So it's a little below the target
we had but
>> a little bit below but it was it was the
best that we had
>> in terms of that those were what we
could draw out. What do you think of all
the things we said work the best?
>> I mean, I I I think I think for me like
the biggest piece was just I think
shifting my mindset cuz like what I was
afraid of coming in was really I didn't
want to be misunderstood that I'm I'm in
this for the money like that that's what
you know and so I think whatever you
coached me with on the call of like Tina
more money you make means more impact
and you getting out and [laughter] what
>> how you did that to me 10 years ago.
Yeah, I
>> was like, I just want to help people. I
was like, can we help people and get
really rich?
>> So, what was unexpected in all of this?
>> I just feel like I collapsed time. I
[music] don't think this would have
happened if I was on my own. Like,
outside of this whole process.
>> Awesome.
>> I've done what I didn't think I could.
>> Good job. I'm really I'm proud of
myself.
>> Great job. [applause]
>> Thank you. going back.
All right, I see before we dive in, I
want to say that you had a lot of stuff
that I told you to do, which in some
ways was a uh you had a lot biggest one
off the top was the associate strategy
getting not just one but multiple
associates so we could offload a bunch
of visits. How did that go?
>> Yeah, so we hired two associates. Both
of them are prior specialists which have
made the transition process much easier.
>> Nice. where we can essentially tell
patients, not lying to them, that these
people [laughter] yeah on paper these
guys are are technically like more
qualified than my dad [music] is
technically.
>> Technically
>> and it makes the offboarding process for
the patient trusting so much easier. On
the contrary, since our sales cycle is
so long, we haven't really reaped the
benefits of that just yet because then
implant takes about a year
>> to get done. That's why so the first two
visits
>> collected cash.
>> We have collected the cash. That's the
thing.
>> And that was one of the things though.
We changed that, didn't we? Yes. Yeah,
we did change that.
>> Yes.
>> So material improvement, I would say.
>> Material improvement 2.5 to one to 111
to one.
>> Yeah. Nothing sounds like proof.
>> Yeah. So good.
>> So, and honestly, I think what it was is
just a lot of limiting beliefs.
>> Of course, that's the game.
>> Telling my dad, you know what, we can
collect up front. He's like, no one's
going to say yes to that. We've always
done it this way. I'm like, do I
>> You can also just say, we've always done
it this way. And when you do the change,
>> exactly.
>> That's right.
>> And always being, you know, the last
week. Google Ads. So, where you at with
that one?
>> So, Google Ads, we're actually still at
12,000. We haven't had to increase
24,000 yet. We're still at capacity
>> sales process.
>> So the VSSL
>> I think when we spoke you hadn't done
that one yet.
>> No VSSLs.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. No VSSLs. I have videos on the
website but just for every single
>> service but no VSSL made.
>> Just think about it as an insurance
policy for the $41,000. That's all this
is. Yeah.
>> Right. And so would you make a video to
guarantee that you collect $41,000?
>> No questions asked.
>> Or just cut the doctor's time in half
too. Cuz like what happens is you take
you know three conversations to two or
two conversations to one or an hour
turns into 30 um and close rates go up.
So it's like your sales efficiency goes
up and your close rate go up which then
once you do those two things you know
what happens next
>> across thousands and thousands of
businesses like I've never seen it not
>> yeah I can't think of a time it hasn't
>> you cannot educate a customer more and
have [music] them be less likely to buy.
Yeah,
>> unless you have a terrible product, in
which case they find out, then that's
not the
>> the organic content machine.
>> Organic content. So, I have I rewatched
your clip. You were talking of like
Shiron was like, "You know what? I'm
posting once a day and I'm not scaling."
And Alex was like, "Huh, I'm posting 700
times a week." [laughter] So, I was
like, "You know what?
What the
>> someone has to run the business.
>> We're running God
[laughter] damn.
I kind of took some inspiration from
Alex and I'm posting a 100 times a day
across all platforms, two accounts.
>> Hello.
>> Yeah.
>> What about the before and after stuff?
>> So before and after. We're taking before
photos. We haven't reached after just
yet for a lot of stuff.
>> That's good. Yeah.
>> Okay. [applause]
>> You going back?
>> So we have two illuminations this round.
We will start with one person who is
safe. How about that?
And the last round was about revenue
growth, right? And so everyone here, you
grew a lot and so that's why you're at
this stage. The next [music] one, this
round is about adherence. And the main
reason for that is because you could
hypothetically just do a bunch of stuff,
random, you know, sell a bunch of
discounted stuff to try and drive up
revenue to get to this round. But in
terms of building the long-term thing,
um, one of the things we have really
commonly here is that the fastest way to
build a $10 million business isn't the
fastest way to build a hundred million
dollar business. And so it's just as
important to build it fast as it is to
build it right. And so that's why the
adherence phase is so important for us,
especially as we think about working
with you guys long term.
>> Yeah.
And so from a purely adherence
perspective, the first person who is
safe for this round
is Tina.
All right. [applause]
>> All right.
>> Then there were three. Okay. So
this one's tough because a lot of you
guys did implement [music] portions of
it and all of you guys did really well.
And so the first elimination
is Caleb.
>> Yeah. Awesome.
>> Please grab a seat [music] and just know
that it has nothing to do with our, you
know, voting for you in terms of uh your
success long term. I'm very confident
that you're going to succeed.
>> Is it possible to say something to you
that I wanted to say like the first
time?
>> Um when I first found your content, man,
like I was working at a region's bank
and I absolutely hated that job. [music]
hated where I was at, all of that. When
I came across your content, it has
dramatically changed my life in so many
different ways. And I appreciate you for
that. And [music] what I want you all to
know is that what you do is super
important. It's so [music] important.
Even me getting like the scroll and
whatnot, it's like a message in a bottle
to the next generation. I got out of a
bad relationship I didn't like. I I
followed so much of your advice. I was
like, "Fuck, man. Let me try Bumble."
That's that's where I met my wife. And
so it was like God [music] put like a
shining light on her. It's like this is
your person right here. And so that
level of commitment is what I've put
into not only my business but how I run
everything.
>> You're already a phenomenal
entrepreneur.
>> Thank you. Appreciate it.
>> Congrats.
>> Where I'm most surprised too, man, is
that like 7 months ago, I was just a
roofing salesman. [music]
But at the end of the day, whether I won
or lost, the aspect of actually
competing in this has made me so much
more potent as an entrepreneur. Despite
the results that came out out there,
these next 90 days, I'm gonna I'm gonna
go be [music] harder to all my
ops. The workshop sucks. Don't come.
[laughter]
>> You know, the thing is is like we have
to do this because it's the nature of
the show.
>> Don't have to. You don't have to.
>> But I hate it. I really want you to
know. I genuinely hate it. Um
>> I can tell.
>> I do.
>> Do you want me to do it?
>> It's so bad. I haven't met with each of
you individually. [laughter]
>> Like I know the stories. bias.
All right,
>> that being said,
>> yeah. All right. Well,
>> okay. So, in terms [music] of who is
advancing to the next round,
that will be Joey.
[applause]
Thanks, man.
>> And dude, I just want to say like you
you've done some really hard with
your dad, the practice.
A lot of times people come in here like
>> it's my parent and we're like yeah
it's just like a well this is going
to suck and
>> really impressive like you had a lot of
things to do which is why from a pure
like from a numbers perspective of
things that you were able to get [music]
done you had a slightly no lower number
but like one of those items was go get
two dental associates [music] which is a
pretty monster single bullet
>> and so just if I had a honorable mention
in terms of [music] like hard like you
did a lot and Caleb, you did a shitload,
too.
>> Thank you, sir.
>> I I also would say that um it's hard
enough to break beliefs for yourself,
>> but doing that for your parent is even
harder.
>> Yeah.
>> Your your immigrant father. [laughter]
>> Yeah,
>> I get it.
>> We get it.
>> We have Actually, you don't have an
immigrant father.
>> Father's still in India.
>> Yeah. Yeah. [laughter] Still there.
Yeah.
Technically, it's just us. [laughter]
>> Uh, but no, hass grants either way. I
mean, you still monstrously improved the
business.
>> Thank you.
>> I did better than I expected. I think um
I didn't think I'd have so much progress
so soon. And it was like a almost like
an explosion of progress. It feels like
you know what, nothing's happening.
Nothing's happening. And then it's like
boom, it happened, which is pretty cool.
um sucks obviously not winning but end
of the day I mean you can't really
[music] complain it's like things are
going well. Yeah.
Okay. So we've gone from 8 to 4 to 2. 90
days ago you guys came out here at, you
know, one-ish million and a little less
than a million. And you've both added
almost over a million. you voted almost
two to the business in 90 days, which is
crazy. But just to remind uh the
audience back home and you guys what
this is all about, my green men.
[laughter]
So uh by the end of today, one of you
guys will walk out with $100,000 and a
golden ticket to work with me and the
team for the next year to continue to
scale. And so that is what that is what
this round is all about. The challenge
for this round is different. So the
first round was about qualifying just
based on growth that makes sense. The
next round was about adherence because
we want to make sure that you're
building the right type of business so
that if we're just giving you things
going forward it's not just chance. It's
like there you guys are actually going
to do it right. Um the third is one that
I think is the most central skill of
being an entrepreneur uh which is sales
because you have to sell investors, you
have to sell employees, you have to sell
customers, you have to sell in your
marketing. The game of entrepreneurship
of selling never really ends. And so
this one is a straight head-to-head
sale. [music]
So you guys will both uh pitch us on why
we should pick your business
specifically.
>> Excited.
>> Yes.
>> All right. So Tina,
>> so you are you're going first.
>> Ready? Okay. Well, first outside of you,
I'm the hardest worker you're going to
meet.
And you should pick me [music] because
I'm the total package. Not only am I
exceptional at delivering [music] client
results, like I have just so many
freaking testimonials.
I am also very experienced in marketing
and sales, but also all aspects of the
[music] business from being in business
for 16 years, working for myself,
starting from when my son was a baby,
working between the hours of 8 8:00 p.m.
and 2:00 in the morning. So bootstrap
from the ground up. And I have a track
record before this. I I still have that
business [music]
uh where I've made over $20 million in a
business that I grew from nothing. So,
sorry.
>> You're good.
>> I'm just like,
>> what was the 20 million from? What was
the business?
>> Changing my lives are changed from being
[music] here, but sorry. Um, and it's a
unique business as well that people
don't think is [music] serious, you
know, like stickers. I teach people how
to coupon
and save [music] money online.
>> That was the old business.
>> That was the old business. I made $20
million in commissions. So, that is
business acumen. You cannot replace.
Um,
I got this. I went out last night. Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> I did this this morning.
>> You're good.
>> But
and I would be successful in any
business,
any business [music]
because I have the raw ingredients and
the experience.
But I'm choosing this business because
it is so much more than just a business.
This is literally changing lives.
The rate of autism is going up at a
gross amount.
And you know what happens when you get a
diagnosis today?
You're handed essentially a life
sentence. They tell you there's nothing
you can do. And that's what families are
handed with now. And so that's why I'm
doing this work. Like this is so much
more than just like a business that you
invest in. And this has like Thank you.
[sighs and gasps]
What do you think
the
hardest part of kind of the next few
years look like? If you had to be down
this path and see the growth, what do
you think that what do you think the gap
or the challenge looks like? The gap's a
challenge I think is removing myself and
my sense of control because I want just
so bad for people to get results and I
[music] just take it personally when
people don't or when when you [music]
know like people aren't happy for
whatever reason cuz not everyone is a
perfect client. So it's really just the
it's personal growth for myself of you
know my capacity to be able to handle
that.
>> All right. Thank you Tina.
>> Thank you
>> sir Joey.
Thank you. First of all, I want to say
like anybody here is incredibly
deserving, but if I have to stand on a
mount of hubris for just a moment. Uh,
first and foremost, I will I so
um I did not go out last night because
this is my entire world. Not to cast
shade, but I repped this rhythm o like
over and over and over again, but I'm
going to toss it out. So, I want to give
you four different buckets of the reason
why I think I'm the I'm the right
investment. And the first one is
quantitative. [music]
you encouraged me to pursue an
acquisition channel that I had no
experience in pursuing and I immediately
put 15 grand in it and made $670,000 as
a result of that. So, the proof is
there. Qualitative. Um, [music] you
mentioned adherence. I did every single
thing on that list. Um, that brings me
to my third bucket, which is heart. Um,
I I [music] like I pour my heart and
soul into this company every single day.
Um,
I left a six-f figureure career after my
mom passed away to take over this
company.
My dad and I had a conversation at the
table. We had someone who wanted to
acquire it. And at the time it was
doing, you know, 100 grand and 150 grand
in revenue. So, like, who's going to
acquire, you know, 100? So, it was like
a it was almost like an insult offer to
be like, you know, we hear about this
thing, like we want to take it off your
plate. And I was like, no, like I'm
going to dive all into this. Like, this
is this is mom's company. like I'm going
all in and I'm going to figure it out.
And so like 13 years later through CO
and weathering that storm, [music] I
pivoted our entire company from an event
planning company to a virtual production
studio overnight when CO happened
because we couldn't do live events, but
people still [music] needed community.
People still fundamentally need
community. The fourth bucket is legacy.
In the same way that my mom passed the
baton to me, I want to be able to pass
the baton to my little girl, Sage, and
her, you know, little [music] brother.
Win or lose, I feel like I've already
won and um I just I appreciate you guys.
Thank you.
>> Praas,
>> that's Spanish for questions.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Gotcha. [laughter]
>> You mentioned um wanting to kind of buy
your time back again soon, which is
probably the only concern that I have
because you always want to buy your time
back to do something that has higher
leverage in the business. And I say this
as somebody knowing that I'm going to go
into a season where I'm not going to
have as much time and I'm not going to
be winning like I was once before. And
I'm okay with that. My first thought
goes like, "How many hours a day do you
guys work? What is too much? What is the
right split? Like what does that look
like?"
>> Yeah, that's fair. I appreciate that.
>> Yeah. We've made a couple investments
where people have said like, "Hey, you
know, we have to have and it's
unfortunately like those investments
just kind of pitterpatter."
>> Yeah. So buying my time back for me is
not about it's not about like sidest
stepping the business. It's more about
like hey can we have someone go do
groceries for us so we don't have to do
that so we could focus on higher
leverage activities. That's what I meant
when I say buying my time back is more
of like what can we eliminate from our
daily tasks that we're doing that cost
us 2 hours a day and pay someone to do
it so that we can focus on higher
leverage things. So I think you know I
think about buying my time back on the
personal side so that I can focus on the
things that are really filling my cup on
the professional side as well.
>> 100%. Thanks for explaining.
>> How big do you want this to be in 12
months?
>> 10 million sounds like a great number
but the goal for me has been I want to
get the company to a million in IBIDA
and I genuinely like that was a six year
five to six year goal for me. I think I
could do that now in 12 months. um a
million IBIDA in 12 months would be a
wonderful goal and then from there it's
like let's figure out what's next.
>> We're going to talk amongst ourselves uh
for a few minutes and then uh and then
we'll do we'll do the final round.
[music]
Okay. So before we tell you the
verdicts, each of us want to give you
kind of pros and cons on how we were
thinking through the decision. Um and
then after each of us gives our pro and
con uh for each of you, we will then uh
cast our vote. [music] I think both of
you have something really special. You
have this big why in your families as to
why you wanted to do this thing. And
Tina, you figured out how to actually do
the hardest thing ever to convert a
passion to a business. Uh Joey, as I sit
here as a we're making an investment in
your business, the one thing that
I think hard [music]
long and hard about is the business
itself. Where is the business
opportunity and where is the scalability
of that opportunity? And that's a um
that's a con for me. And so if I combine
those those two things, uh my vote for
this round is going to be Tina.
I think you're both really enthusiastic
and industrious. Um, which I think are
two things that are really vital to
being a great entrepreneur. So, kudos to
both of you because that's two of the
biggest pieces. So, I think that's
really important. Joey, I think you're
very steady and calculated, which I
appreciate. I think that that's needed,
especially as a company gets bigger and
you want to scale and um to prepare like
you did. It's clear that there's a lot
of intention. I think that says a lot
cuz I always say watch what they do, not
what they say. Um, and so I'm watching
for what you guys are doing rather than
what you're saying to me. So that stood
out. In terms of con, um, I think the
business opportunity itself, um, is,
dare I say, mid compared to some other
opportunities that we've invested in. So
I think that in order to maximize on an
opportunity like that and make the
investment worthwhile, it's going to be
violent execution. Um, Tina, I think you
are incredibly coachable and I really
respect that. Um, but to be honest, the
con was hearing you went out last night
and did all this this morning. I can't
think of a time I would have done that
with an opportunity this important. So,
that was jarring to me. So, that was a
con.
So, because of that, my pick for this
round is Joey.
>> All right.
All right. So then I'm I'm the the
deciding vote. Pluses. Um Tina,
one of the things that we talked about
90 days ago um was that I wanted to make
sure that you were technically
proficient and that you could pull off a
lot of these things. And I think the
history that you have with the affiliate
marketing um has carried over into this
uh business. [music] And so the fact
that you are technically proficient,
created a lot of tools very quickly. Um
the business is already online. So we
don't have to worry about kind of
physical locations. Um I think you have
dramatically improved your client
delivery ratio so that we could really
scale this. Um and so for me the
technical proficiency and combined with
the scalability of the model I see as a
major pro. Um from the cons perspective
um I'll say less about the you know the
fact that you went out last night or
whatever. I would say that the judgment
of telling us was the bigger mistake.
The other part that I would say is a con
is that I think that the pitch could
have been significantly more structured
um than [music] it was. Um I think you
kind of were trying to find your way as
you were as you were going through it.
Um and this is definitely the time where
you want to you want to nail it.
Joey um
pros LTV to CAC really really strong. I
mean probably some of the strongest that
we have in the room. Um, I also really
like the fact that the business is
reoccurring in nature. So, the fact that
we already have four million books for
next year and we can [music]
consistently demonstrate like year over
year we'll be able to continue to stack
this business. Um, which I see as a
really really big uh pro also kind of
weathering the co storm [music]
uh specifically for your business.
Obviously, we're in the gym industry and
so I would say I have a special
appreciation for people who who didn't
jump ship during those periods of time
and you stuck through it. And so, like
if you stuck with the business when you
weren't [music] legally allowed to do
the business, which I see as a pretty
good limit test of how committed you
are, um I see that as a as a major pro.
Cons, um the business, it doesn't cash
flow as much as I would like. Um it is
lower margin that I would prefer uh from
the styles of business that I like to
invest in. So, one of the things I found
interesting that both of you missed in
your pitches was that neither of you
talked about what I might want as an
investor. And so, whenever I'm selling
anything, I always have to start with
[music] what is you reverse engineer
from the prospect. And so, an investor
is going to want something that's going
to be fast growing, highly profitable,
defensible. And I didn't hear anything
[music] about that. Um, and so I think
that was probably the biggest miss that
both of you guys had in your pitches to
us. And so
my vote goes to real quick before I
reveal the winner. The average increase
in revenue of all these contestants was
2.4x in 90 days. So two almost two and a
half times. And in absolute terms, they
added over a million dollars in revenue
and over $500,000 in profit in 90 days.
And a large reason they were able to do
that is because they had a very clear
plan based on where they were at right
now. And so I would like to give you one
of my most prized possessions as a gift,
which is the scaling road map. These
guys followed the same plans which I
highlighted in each of their individual
episodes, showing exactly where they're
at and what they needed to do. And I'd
like to give it to you absolutely free.
So click the link, you can grab it, and
maybe in the next 90 days you can do the
same thing, too. Of course, not a
promise. Your results will vary,
obviously. Back to the show.
So,
my vote goes to
[applause]
Do you remember you said 90 days ago I
get to kiss you? Oh, don't uh [laughter]
do not do that.
>> And so with this Joey, congratulations.
You have the $100,000 investment and
we'll be working together for the next
year on scaling your business. And uh
you are the winner. Congrats, MAN.
[laughter]
>> I almost didn't apply for the show and
now I've won the show. [music]
And so like I would tell you like bet on
yourself. Spend the money to come out
here and learn from a team that is in
like you get such depth of experience
when you're here in this community of
people. Come out here and learn from
other entrepreneurs.
>> I think the the larger message that I
would love for the entrepreneurs who are
watching this, what you guys all showed
in 90 days is that [music] you can have
absolutely violent commitment to a plan
and achieve years worth of results in 90
days. And so [music] it doesn't matter
how bad your current situation is,
you can change your stars [music] in a
very short period of time. And so thank
you guys for watching and uh you can hit
below if you want to join the next round
and we'll see you on the next scale or
fail.